bioluminescence is the scintillating
effect of a living thing emitting light
and in a small coastal town in central
Japan one glowing creature is also a
delicacy - Yama Bay is around 4000 feet
deep one of the deepest bays in all of
Japan and home to one of the only
commonly edible bioluminescent species
in the world with us Callisto this Jota
Ricardo used this new John Allen Ingram
with a mask a door we operated in a
simple in a Colorado Firefly squid
fishing isn't a normal fishing job they
have to fish in the dead of night
bioluminescent sea creatures prefer the
dark depths of the ocean but the Firefly
squid lights of the shores when they
spawn making them easier to catch it is
honey sauce their ninja new upon them
manage their Jimmy Osama's soda Cara
Santini don't need personal Oh it'll be
the hero our hero hiding desk at all
irony Sam that was our papa
you only have a Papa hiding us where is
all that squid going well to places like
capillo rocky a small Japanese
restaurant an American economist co2 ah
and hunger you know eat a - Papa D
colosso Dario who are suddenly happier
Adriana so you added scales to a massive
ramekin rhetorical mommy Tina wah hota
recollection Morales named Hamato a
mango amok they I see we don't know
audio poker night it's good or deceased
every muscle
chef Iraqis menu include multiple
variants of Firefly squid from salted to
grilled boiled to sashimi all of them
delicious and most importantly
as our hero your lowest series on the
mosquito Amos
[Music]